[Music]
well hello and welcome
to i'd like to know this is our question
and answer our bible question and answer
program and thank you for joining us
today i'm in the company of my pastor my
friend pastor stephen bohr president and
speaker for secrets unsealed i am c.a
murray and as we often say this is one
of our favorite programs because it
allows us to answer your question to see
what's on your mind and in your heart
and it allows us to go back to the word
of god and study and we as always make
you this promise that if
an answer can be found from the word of
god we will find it and we will bring
you answers only as based on the word of
god
we are too late in this earth's history
to be dealing with the mind of men we
want the word of the lord amen and we
promise to give you the word of the lord
should you have a question that you
would like us to wrestle with a little
bit you can send
your question to
tv
at some tv
dot o r g that's tv
at some
s-u-m-t-v
dot o-r-g and we will get to your
question as soon as possible
we have
an impressive stack of questions in fact
we were just given a big bunch of
questions just this week an extra stack
to put under the stack that is here we
will get to them uh we don't like to
rush through the questions we want to
give each one due diligence and due time
so uh we're not going for speed per se
we're going for thoroughness and
accuracy as the it speaks the word of
god so pastor boy if you would open with
prayer we'll get right to our questions
for this week
let's pray father in heaven we come
before your
throne
in the powerful name of jesus what a
privilege it is to speak in prayer to
the king of the universe
knowing that you
hear us
and you answer our prayers
we ask that as we begin this program to
answer these questions that people have
sent
that you will be with us to guide our
thoughts
that we might answer the questions in
harmony with your holy word
that the answers might be beneficial to
the personal walk of each individual
with jesus christ
so we plead we crave your presence in
this program
and we ask this
in the precious and all-powerful name of
jesus amen amen amen amen
pastor our first question comes to us
from
vincenzo i suspect
it's either garlino or guyena
and g-a-l-l-i-n-a
and um
he has a bible question
uh in genesis chapter 11 verse 13
it says that a foxhead
begat sayla or salah
but in luke 3 36 we read that
kanan not or yeah kanan not a foxhead
was the son
of
okay of a foxhead could you please
explain
well the bottom line is that in the
genealogies
you don't necessarily always have
the son of a father and then a son of
that individual
you many times have just a descendant
yes uh and so it's it's possible that in
genesis 11
salah
was a descendant and also in luke
chapter 3 canaan was a descendant
doesn't necessarily mean specifically
the son
as such yes it doesn't mean the direct
sun the direct uh offspring of that
individual but in that line in that
family right in that family right uh
there is some uh room for uh
a little wiggle room i guess we can say
uh the way the bible does that well done
well said i think so
well that one was uh actually quite easy
to answer very quickly
uh here we have another question and a
lot of this is basically commentary
i'm going to read the entire thing this
is sent by anna
and that reads like this
i hope i find you well
where your hope has been fulfilled we
are well
through reading the gospels i have
observed that jesus did not stay in one
place
or rather he did not have an office
but went from place to place to preach
the gospel
why don't our pastors do the same
the jobs in the offices that the pastors
are doing
can't they be done by layman
is not the job of a pastor to preach the
gospel
so why are they confined in the offices
this is creating a shortage of pastors
where i live as soon as a pastor
advances further academically he is put
in an office
sometimes the title pastor is also
dropped only doctor title remains
i am not against our pastors getting
degrees
because this helps them to reach the
educated
why can't they be called pastor first
and foremost and then put the title
doctor at the end of the name
and then there's a second question
secondly during jesus time there was a
lot of demonic activities
people were sick
or lame because of demon possession so
why are demons not being cast out these
days does that mean the demons are no
longer at work so let's take the first
question about pastors occupying offices
once they get their doctorate
[Music]
you know
having
worked in the pastor
as a pastor and having served in the in
the office
i i see the dilemma
because once you show some ability and
and
this may not even be paid to to a higher
degree once you so show some pastoral
ability they tend to take that ability
out of the church and put in the office
so the churches lose a person who has
shown that they have some ability um
i was just mentioning a little bit ago
that
my stepson is uh pastoring in a
conference and he has been added has had
added to his portfolio uh associate
ministerial and
sabbath uh public affairs religious
liberty besides being a jewish pastor
pardon me besides being a church man but
he's still in the church so they've
added those things
um and he's not going into the office
he's staying in his home he's staying
near his church he's pastoring his
church and he has those added i think
that may be the best way to do it so
that you don't lose a good person but
you have to be a little careful in
adding these other responsibilities
because you tend to dilute his time for
pastoring and pastoring if done
correctly is a full-time job
you know
time to study time to visit my last
church i visited my my sick list was was
60 70 people uh so it took a lot of time
just to get around new york city to to
visit them but i i i feel her pain here
because we do lose many good men to the
office who perhaps would do better
staying in the church
i think so i think you know
for example if an individual is a
successful evangelist
they take him out of
evangelism
and they put him in an office to
coordinate evangelism
when really the person would be far more
effective
continuing to do evangelism and maybe
taking some individuals under his wing
or under her wing because there's women
evangelists as well and becoming a
mentor to multiply
his influence and reach
by by
you know helping others become
successful evangelists yes i know some
office men and and maybe this is a
church showing a bit of an enlightenment
uh as far as evangelism is concerned uh
certain presidents certain office people
go out and continue to do evangelism i
know the general conference president uh
tries at least once a year to go out and
do active
you know public evangelism uh and i
think that's a good thing first of all
you get that you get that expertise but
then he keeps his skills sharp and uh
you get another voice for the lord in
the in the community yeah
one of the one of the sad things about
being in the office and i've been in the
office uh you know i was four and a half
years ministerial director an evangelist
for the texas conference and i was using
pathfinder for six years in new jersey
one of the things that i did not like
about office work and i was in the field
a lot as well
is that you
really don't get that connection
with the people yes you know like at
fresno central i was there 20 years
i saw kids born
hatched
and matched
i baptized them
i got really really acquainted with the
family
because you're constantly visiting
you're constantly seeing them in church
you know you have that fellowship
which you don't have in the office
because in the office you're going to
one church on one sabbath to another
church and another sabbath to another
church and another sabbath and so
there's something really special about
pastoral work you know i enjoyed my last
20 years of ministry which was half of
my denominational ministry as pastor of
fresno central church wow praise the
lord you know i it's funny i've never
stayed in the church at hell and they
moved me so fast uh
the longest i ever pastored one church
was
seven years
then into the office but they they kind
of moved me along i would have loved to
spend 20 years in one church in 20 years
i pastored i think five churches
they moved me every three years and
changed but uh i enjoyed pastoral
ministry i really did yeah there's
something very very well so um we
understand uh your burden and we share
that burden uh we do because we need to
um
uh
maybe let these guys stay in the
churches that they're doing such a fine
job yeah and there's a shortage of
pastors even to this day
you know we have um at secrets unsealed
we have offices
[Laughter]
we do office work yes but really secrets
unsealed is all about preaching
you know we do sabbath school we do the
worship service we do i'd like to know
we do symposiums anchor school of
theology uh you know so so we're
constantly preaching yeah besides what
we do in the office yes so you know i
think one of the big problems is
that many times pastors
don't actually do much studying
and therefore you know the food that
they give to the congregation is not
really solid food
you know it's like like on friday night
i say well well i'm gonna preach
tomorrow and so let's see let's look up
let's look up three or four stories and
find a couple of verses and attach those
and that will be my servant for tomorrow
you know that's irresponsible yes
because one of the duties of the pastor
is to feed the congregation visit
lead and feed the congregation are the
two main tasks of a pastor yes that that
friday night thing kind of makes it fast
food or junk food yeah and i remember
hearing a fella say the other day uh
there's no such thing as junk food
there's only junk and food you know i
mean
that's a good way we need to give our
people food not just not junk yeah there
you go okay what do we say about the
second question about um you know are
the demons no longer at work because we
don't see demons being cast out these
days
i think
the truth about demonic activity is it's
still around satan is still alive and
well sadly uh and he works with
unceasing energy so are there still
demons is there still demonic activity
yes
very much so the thing is we've gotten
so sophisticated that you know if you
can name it then you can take it out of
the realm of of demonic activity well
that's psycho yada yada blah blah blah
but uh sometimes it's just plain old
demonic possession and expressions of
the of the devil
and you know i have seen cases during my
ministry of direct demon possession yes
and it's a scary thing you know you have
to make sure that your relationship with
the lord is strong
because you don't want to mess with the
devils no so so there are
cases of demon possession even in the
21st century
and they're still casting out of demons
in the 21st century but the devil has
found a different way of doing it you
know he has what i call sophisticated
demon possession yes not people who foam
at the mouth and there's there's a
different voice coming out of their
mouth
but rather
individuals that are under under the
influence
of satan's power and they're doing
things that is demon possessions but
it's a more sophisticated type of demon
possession yes yes very very true i uh
have preached this we we know of a lady
who's who's a quote mother used to come
visit her every afternoon you know her
mother had been dead for ten years and
she would come about two o'clock in the
afternoon she would come in and have a
talk with her then when she found out
the woman found out that uh
the dead know nothing and and became
venice the mother stopped visiting
stopped coming back you know because she
knew the truth yeah and you know
right around the time of the cri of
christ's first coming
the demonic world kicked into action yes
because they knew that the messiah was
going to come see they know the prophecy
of the 70 weeks they knew approximately
the time when the messiah was going to
come
and so they kicked into action the
demonic
are we to expect less as we near the
second coming of christ are we to expect
less demon activity than
in relationship to the first coming i
believe that we're going to see more and
more
direct demon possession as well as the
sophisticated type so-called and i'll
tell you another time when the demonic
world kicked into activity around 1844.
yes if you look at the the
utopian societies and the dystopian
societies and the phalanx societies um
mary baker eddie's christian science yes
yes uh many yep many conferences
to adventism uh and the fox sisters and
even in certain aspects of the civil war
and we don't have time to go through all
of that but um illinois has many
statements to to make about demon
activity and people speaking to and
listening to devils uh in the civil war
so uh satan is very aware of scripture
he knows it very very well sadly maybe
somewhat better than many uh of us who
ought to know more or certainly many in
the adventist church so he is working
with all lying wonders and
deceivableness and you are quite right
do we think he's going to go out with
less of a bang than when he came in i
think not so we can look for more of
this not less as we get closer to the
second coming of jesus christ i agree
well let's go to the next question
this guy actually comes from kenya
and this is the question i don't get
this right
is it true that women should always
cover their heads in church
or what is paul really addressing i
think this would be first corinthians
chapter 11 if i'm not mistaken where
paul
gives counsel to women in a church
context
so what can we say about this particular
question
it would be i think in first corinthians
chapter 11 if i'm not mistaken
[Music]
and we are in 11 00 or is it second
corinthians 11.
yeah first corinthians chapter 11.
there we go
i think verse 3 has the key
but i want you to know
that the head of every man is christ
the head of the woman is a man
and the head of christ is god you know
people have no problems with
the part that says the head of every man
is christ
they don't have any issue with
the head of christ as god the issue is
with the man being the head of the woman
and
the entire passage which speaks about
covering the women covering their head
has to do with submission
the the woman in submission to the man
in a church worship context yes yes
isn't it interesting that
nowadays women don't have to have their
head covered and if a guy walks around
with a hat on he's kind of out of place
so things have so there are some
cultural aspects of this but there's
also the the understanding uh that
christ is ahead it's a a
yielding of one's mind and body in
submission to the headship of jesus of
jesus christ and you know the apostle
paul in this passage gives the
impression that women's long hair would
serve
or serve as the veil
you know long hair and he gives the
impression that men should have short
hair
and in that cultural context and that
women should have long hair and that the
hair of the woman would be her head
covering the worship context precisely
uh you know i think the important thing
here
is the principle
and not necessarily the way in which the
principle is manifested within that
culture
and i've given this example before but
probably there are people who are
connected who
have not seen this before
you know one time i went into the home
of one of my church members and he had a
whole pile of books and
the bible was at the very bottom of the
pile
all of the books were on top
and that kind of bothered me because you
always know that the bible has to go on
top right
there's no doubt about it the bible has
to be on top of all the other books so
so i was so much bothered that i said
brother
what is that bible doing under all those
books
he says what's the problem
i said the bible should all be always be
on top of all of the other books he said
why because i said well the bible
is on top of all knowledge
he says yes but the bible is also the
foundation of all knowledge
[Laughter]
who was right who was right
actually
both were right
you know it all depends on
uh the manifestation of the principle
the principle is that the bible is above
all
the way in which the principle is
manifested can vary yes yes i remember
and it's funny you go off on these
little tangents i remember being taught
early on that you don't put anything on
top of your bible it's just tradition
you know you don't and i remember
visiting a a sister and um i had my
sabbatical lesson out and i put my sabs
glass on the top of my bible and she was
pretty incense you know you take that
lesson off your bible you know
i didn't i never thought to say it's the
foundation i just she was quite a bit
older than me so i just dutifully took
my lesson off my bible and she was quite
fine and the seven school quarterly is
semi semi holy right
it's a religious it's a religious
document
[Laughter]
anyway well uh i hope that uh
that this doesn't become an issue in any
church you know in latin america there's
still older women
who put on a veil when they go to church
yes you know it's harking back to this
in first corinthians chapter 11
okay let's go to our next question this
name this question comes from ethiopia
so we got one from kenya now we have one
from ethiopia thank you
for sending us your questions not only
in the us but sending us questions from
all over the world
and i think we've answered this one
before but maybe we can give a short
answer
my question will be about the christmas
tree
on adventist homepage 482 paragraph one
ellen white wrote god would be well
pleased if on christmas each church
would have a christmas tree on which
shall be hung offerings great and small
for these houses of worship
therefore what is the background on
which ellen white said this
and if we are allowed to do this doesn't
this promote idol worship in churches
i think
i would start
to
answer her question
by pulling out that little phrase
doesn't this promote idol worship
the
availability of doing certain things
many times is dependent upon the motive
that that perceives it or undergirds it
churches
having trees
on which money can be hung
for the poor for the upkeep of the
church or whatever charitable reason
is not idol worship
putting up a tree
as as as a pagan might and worshiping
that tree and worshiping the fact that
it's green all year long
is out of worship right so a lot has to
do
with the motive which with which you
with with which you do something and
that's what ellen white is hearkening to
is alluding to yeah you know satan has
stolen
the symbols that belong to god yes
you know the ancients worship the son
right
they worship the object the son
the ancients worshiped idols of stone
the the bottom line is this
they worshiped the object
so when we have a christmas tree in a
church
do we see the church members bowing down
and worshiping the tree
no the tree becomes a symbol yes satan
led people to worship the literal son to
worship literal idols of stone
but we understand that the sun is a
symbol of christ
[Music]
jesus is the rock it's a symbol of
christ we don't worship the object we
worship the individual to whom the
object
points yes
and and the same with evergreen tree
i've always looked at the evergreen tree
which is what ellen white is addressing
here
as a symbol of christ
not it's not not christ an idol right it
is a symbol of christ
because
the evergreen tree is as its name
indicates it's the same
in winter
summer
spring
and fall it's always green evergreen
like jesus is the same yesterday today
and forever amen
so i've never seen anyone in the church
consider that the tree is an object of
worship
it's just a symbol and when we place our
offerings on the tree
symbolically we're saying that we're
giving our offerings to jesus christ
when i was a pastor in wyoming
at christmas time and i know i'll get
flack over this because there's some
individuals that that will not agree and
they'll have to also digress from ellen
white in this because ellen white
clearly says that god would be pleased
by having a christmas tree an evergreen
tree in the in the church
uh every christmas
we would buy these little hearts uh in
the craft store that had a little thing
to hang with
and
there would come to a point in the
worship service where we would invite
the children to give their hearts to
jesus
and they would bring their little red
hearts and they would hang their little
red hearts on the tree and we were
explained that the tree was a symbol of
christ you're really representing the
fact that you're giving your heart to
jesus
and the kids really look forward to that
every year that i was there they look
forward to doing that giving their
hearts to jesus
so
like you said it depends on the
motivation ellen white says you can make
christmas whatever you want to make it
precisely you can celebrate it in an
idolatrous way like the world does yes
or you can celebrate it in a different
perspective
and so the motive determines the value
of the act according to the spirit of
prophecy yes to to to
blatantly say or to flat out say pagans
did it is is not enough there's another
question that needs to be asked what did
they do it for right and are we doing it
like they did it the way they did it for
the same reasons so you must ask both of
those questions what do they do and why
did they do it and we don't do it for
the same reasons that the act may look
the same it's a tree it's a tree but
we're not worshiping that tree we're
using it as as motivation to do
something good for someone else
i remember there was this big debate
some time ago
whether
our churches should have a cross on them
i don't know if you remember that but do
you know the cross cross is a pagan
symbol well the cross
can be considered a pagan symbol if you
consider it in the in the
perspective of
the period of apostasy in the church but
it can also represent something very
profound yes it can represent the death
of jesus christ on the cross for our
sins
so once again the motivation
comes into play
you know we don't worship the cross
we worship the savior who was placed on
the cross
and and so we need to make that clear
that when there's a cross you know
on the church steeple or whatever
it's not a pagan symbol from the
perspective of the motivation for which
it is being used yeah we we
in it's it's foundational to
protestantism
uh we serve a god who is relational who
cares about relationships which is why
we don't baptize under his children they
haven't developed a relationship with
with christ and the same way on the
other end it's why we don't do extreme
function or or
that last service before a person dies
because we're dealing with relationship
not the sacrament that saves you it's
the relationship that saves right and
this falls under that capital amen
well i'll tell you what time just flies
by doesn't it
and so we're near the end so any final
words of wisdom see you know again this
this idea of relationship you know get
to know christ
may all the things that you do be
motivated by your love for your
relationship with jesus christ amen and
as such uh therein is your salvation not
the not the evil name of your church or
the sacrament but your relationship with
christ that will keep you and amen the
thing that saves you
god bless you see you next time
[Music]
you